hey there heather that fire right behind
us we're at a safe distance we're inside
the recycling center getting a look at
what is happening right now we have
three ladder trucks shooting water from
the air we are told thankfully no
reports of injuries and right now the
cause is still unknown just about 50
firefighters on the scene and they
expect to stay out here for several more
hours they told us as you can see in the
larger screen on your television screen
we have video from north las vegas fire
department showing the flames and the
stacks of cardboard that were on fire
when they got here they tell us they
first got word of this around five
o'clock this morning they're going to be
out here for quite some time as they
make sure all of that cardboard along
with some plastic is out again just to
reiterate thankfully no reports of
injuries cause is still unknown but the
smoke we see here in the air in terms of
uh around the valley you'll still see
that smoke for several more hours
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you